spring of course brings that nice warmer
weather Mary Jane was just talking about
but it also means more allergy issues
there are even certain types of trees
banned in Clark County due to the high
levels of pollen they produce Madison
Kimbrough spoke with the horticulturist
about the history behind these trees and
locals on how they're coping with all
this she joins us live in studio tonight
with more Sasha this is definitely the
time where people get out their tissue
boxes and nasal spray and tonight we
hear from an expert who shares how
Mulberry and olive trees are some of the
biggest culprits in spreading pollen
around in the air
I have all environmental allergies I
have all of Mulberry Sage but yet I have
one in my backyard usually because I
live on this side the east side so it's
an older area so you have mostly olive
trees Mulberry Karen Hernandez and
Friends enjoying a Saturday night out at
the park seems like a simple outing but
when you've got allergies like them it
can be a nuisance red itchy eyes
sneezing dry eye coughing I take double
dose of allergy medicine I you know did
two different kinds of allergy medicine
on top of my vitamins and even then it's
not enough that we often associate
environmental allergies with specific
allergens some people are sensitive to
irritants in the air
with tree pollen being one of the
biggest reasons people's respiratory and
immune systems act up during this time
of year
Mulberry and olive trees even considered
a public health hazard as Clark County
banned them from being sold or planted
here over 30 years ago but there are
some exceptions horticulturalist Norm
Schilling explains the males are no
longer allowed to be sold in southern
Nevada by law and the same is true of
fruiting olives fruitless olives are
still allowed Shilling adding that
fruitless olive trees still produce
flowers but not pollen and as for those
who already have these trees in their
backyard there is a way to maintain them
so that your allergies aren't affected
as much so you can get a high pressure
nozzle and and actually physically spray
water on the tree and that will reduce
the pollen
and you'll see most of these trees in
older parts of town as they can live for
decades here in the desert and don't
need much water to live and grow Sasha